vous avez entendu parler des questions
qu'ont tous les deux ouais
très bon imaginez première question
premier répond question avec tous les
deux non je la pose au delà enfin ça va
être concerne la première je pense
qu'elle te quand ça aurait pu être plus
toi c'est à dire que un jour tu décides
de faire un enfant et puis tu t'aperçois
que tu peux plus en avoir pour des
raisons tu peux plus en avoir et
tu cherches une mère porteuse et
mireille mathieu te propose d'être ta
mère porteuse est ce que tu acceptes tu
vois ce que tu refuses a d'abord je vais
faire un test et de bissy dad ouais
ouais et sinon oui
y'a pas de problème non non pourquoi non
je sais pas je te demande fut question
deuxième question est à toi si tu veux
savez quoi cette correspondante est un
peu mieux aussi à qui se trouve le plus
de circonstances atténuantes à un vieux
qui se tape des petits garçons pour de
l'argent ou un petit garçon qui tapent
sur des vieux toujours pour de l'argent
[Rires]
aucun aucun aucun a des circonstances
atténuantes suis très moral finalement
quoi hein
et toi
j'ai pas réfléchi c'est lui qui
réfléchit pas d'accord j'ai compris
alors à toi maintenant d'accord est-ce
que tu serais prêt à mourir maintenant
la commune a subitement
prendre carrière finie net porte pour
que l'apartheid soit immédiatement
supprimées en afrique du sud non pas que
cela l'autre jour tu as posé une
question sur la faim dans le monde en
prenant 6 ans et 10 mois pour moi tu es
prête à mourir si on peut le faire à
l'anglais pour des trucs qui sont là
toute la planète rassurent pas pour un
pays ça vaut pas le coup d'envoi ça va
faire plaisir aux autres
alors imaginez tous les lilas dans un
chalet tout c'est bien con exécution
vous êtes tous les deux ans dans un
chêne montagne puis lui les mornes et
épices ouattara notre à bouffer je mange
mais tu commences par câble suis
d'accord mais tu commences parfois assez
ça avec moi surtout dire pop là
là mais je suis dans la tête parce que
comme ça au moi je le verrais plus la
cervelle non la figure oh non non mais
on veut pas qu'une bonne petite sauce
gribiche oui parce qu'on
rit but
des biches quoi vous êtes morts tous les
sports tous les deux au préfet un cachet
en stone et charden yoko et john ou
pierre et marie curie pierre et marie
curie pourquoi même vachement sérieux en
fait
yoko
alors question qu'on traditionnel la
bombe arrive dans le cinq minutes que
c'est
moi je me tapais inverse de jack
daniel's je fais un grand buzz à 4 et
puis voilà tétouan 80 d'abord le baiser
de janeiro pour l'année parce que là
vous avez une solution peut vous
échapper à votre juste avant que l'avion
barry via un verdit ne vous appelle vous
dicter les gens comme paul a laissé
crever le super bon on vous met dans un
vaisseau spatial vous cacher sur la lune
ou sur mars marchait pas ou là où c'est
bien là où y'a pas de bombe mais il ya
trois places dans le vaisseau spatial et
comme virgin ils vont ils nous ont pris
un troisième passage chez renault c'est
bien faire ou non
renouvellement non
ppda guy lux ou sabatier
france a battu et je crois avant ouais
pourquoi guy lux il arrête pas donner
trop comment on va aiguiser jusqu'en
petite vidéo est trop sérieuses a battu
le harfang darabont peugeot du casino
avec le sourire
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars d'études abonnez vous je m'étais
1 pouces bleus